rarement le sigle sos aura autant mérité
d'être répété il ya maintenant un an que
nous avons attiré votre attention sur
l'effroyable sécheresse qui ravage tous
les pays du sahel en afrique une
sécheresse qui en fait commencé à se
faire sentir il ya cinq ans mais la
situation ne cesse de s'aggraver et
aujourd'hui 1800 personnes meurent
chaque jour entre l'océan atlantique et
l'océan indien
une nouvelle fois la croix rouge
internationale vient d'ailleurs de
lancer encore un cri d'alarmé
l'europe donne un pour cent de ce
qu'elle récolte du sein
ceylan donné le double c'est à dire
seulement 2% on pourrait sauver toute
une région qui est en train de mourir
par manque d'eau certes cette région et
d'immenses le dakar à la côte est de
l'afrique le sahel s'étend sur une
distance égale à celle de paris à new
york près de 5000 km mais là-bas à
quatre ou cinq heures de paris
on meurt maintenant chaque jour un
groupe de médecins américains a
découvert qu'au mali en mauritanie en
haute volta et en hiver
cent mille personnes sont déjà mortes
ces derniers mois des causes directes ou
indirectes de la sécheresse les pays
riches apportent certes le raid
mais le mal ne cesse de gagner car
maintenant il ne suffit plus l'envoyer
en afrique des céréales ou du lait il
faut donner aux africains des moyens de
transport pour distribuer jusqu'au fond
du désert les sacs de riz ou de sorgho
qui s'entassent inutilement dans les
ports et dans les villes
or les africains sont eux aussi victimes
de l'augmentation du prix du pétrole et
ils ne peuvent plus payer eux mêmes le
transport des livres qu'on leur donne
l'essence est trop chère
les plus touchés comme toujours dans ces
cas sont d'abord les enfants
ensuite les femmes et les vieillards
quant aux troupeaux de ces populations
qui ne vivaient que de leur existence
eh bien il n'existe plus en ethiopie par
exemple un village entier a disparu
c'est le premier que l'on connaît mais
on sait que beaucoup d'autres ont déjà
été rayés de la carte
dans ce village il n'y avait plus un
seul survivant toutes les femmes et tous
les enfants étaient morts de faim
quant aux hommes ont suivi leurs traces
dans le désert il était parti à la
recherche d'un peu de nourriture
on n'a même pas retrouvé leurs corps
l'aide actuelle porte sur 1 million 300
mille tonnes de céréales
il en faudrait deux millions et demi
pour éviter une catastrophe une
catastrophe qui se prépare sous nos yeux
à notre porte
il reste encore sept mois avant que la
prochaine récolte porte ses fruits à
condition bien sûr qu'il pleuve et que
d'ici là les populations du sahel n'est
pas manger les semences faute de mieux
alors dans ce cas là il sera trop tard
il ira trop de morts et tout un pays
n'existera plus